Prof: We are going to
try to finish with
Inferno today and I would
like to look at the last Cantos
XXX, XXXI, XXXII maybe a little
bit, XXXIII for sure,
and there are a couple of
details in XXXIV.
From one point of view,
I'll be talking about Dante's
tragic mode at the bottom of
Hell.
This is--I hope to argue with
you that--I will be arguing
exactly, this is a tragic
representation.
As soon as I say that,
you might wonder,
you probably should wonder,
about the difficulty of such an
enterprise.
And the difficulty of the
enterprise has to do,
first of all,
with the fact that this is a
comedy.
So that difficulty should go
away in the sense that the
tragic is really part not an
end,
not a final vision,
but part of a larger discourse
that Dante will go into,
which is a comical idea.
He really has this idea of a
comical vision,
even of the divinity and
certainly of the cosmos.
Comical, in the sense that it's
really the feast,
the feast--in classical times,
it would be the feast of the
gods.
Here is the redemptive,
happy, harmonious sense of the
whole.
That's one of the difficulties.
The other difficulty
that--about this mode of the
tragic is that the--
within the Christian vision
that Dante--
that sort of shapes Dante's
poem, it's very difficult to
locate the tragic:
there is no such a thing as a
Christian tragedy.
Though one might say,
and I will say here,
just to sort of give you a
sense of how nuanced the issue
maybe,
is that within that vision,
within that Christian vision,
we are always told that the
only thing we know of God's
presence in history is the
Crucifixion.
There's the story of the dying
god, the story of the suffering
of the divinity itself.
It is not, once again,
a final vision.
So there's a theological
problem that he has to confront
and there is also an aesthetic
problem, a larger aesthetic
problem.
To really clarify these issues,
rather than just telling you
that all this comes from--I will
look at these cantos from one
point view.
The point of view of Dante's
writing a particular text,
a text about language.
So it's really going to be
about language and tragedy,
in the belief that this is
exactly Dante's insight about
what the tragic may be.
Let me tell you--I have to go a
little bit outside of the text
for a while--
so that when I point out
details here that we'll talk
about in other texts you will
see what I mean.
You know--this is a sort of
also a little bit of a
recapitulation for you--you know
that Dante goes into exile in
1302.
By that time,
he had written only one book,
an autobiographical book that
had he--the Vita nuova,
the New Life.
Had he written only that book,
he would still be known as one
of the great poets of the Middle
Ages,
but he would not really be
known for more than that.
It's a little bit of a
self-enclosure,
a lyrical poem,
self-enclosed:
it's about,
as you recall,
a kind of sense that the self
is absolute,
that love is an absolute itself.
It does not allow for the
intrusion of anything within its
own orbit and its perimeter and
Dante finishes it off with a
vision,
realizing that he has to do
other things in order to go on
writing.
He just doesn't write much at
that point.
He may be writing some songs.
He is involved in political
life, in the footsteps of his
teacher,
Brunetto Latini,
and hoping that his life will
really be very different from
Brunetto Latini.
Ironically, it is not,
because actually it's even more
tragic than Brunetto Latini's
life,
because Brunetto Latini is
politically involved in the
history of Florence.
He will experience exile,
but he will return to Florence
enough to even go on teaching
Dante.
He has written encyclopedic
texts, like the
Trésor;
he has written allegories,
autobiographical allegories
about his life.
Dante will go into exile in
1302 and the first thing that he
writes is a treatise on language
which is called On the Vulgar
Tongue.
It's a text that--written from
the perspective of exile,
very much like the Divine
Comedy,
because, as I repeat,
Dante will never go back to
Florence.
The reasons why he writes this
kind of text--it's written in
Latin--the reasons are very
unclear, also because he never
finishes it.
I'm going to suggest to you
that there are good reasons why
he could never finish it,
but he wrote two books.
We don't even know how many he
had conceived of writing.
What is this text about?
Let me give you a little bit of
a summary of the text and then
you will see how it will go on
reappearing in Dante's poem,
the final cantos of
Inferno,
where in effect,
he rewrites,
he writes and gives a whole--
a sense of the wholeness of
this text and the difficulties
of--
and he will share with us his
sense of the difficulties why
that tract could never have been
finished.
At any rate it starts,
it's called the De vulgari
eloquentia as it deals with
the origin of the vulgar
tongues.
He starts very much like
medieval treatises start with--
from a metaphysical standpoint,
from the very high:
what does human language do,
is language something human and
the answer that he gives is yes
and no.
It is human because we are the
only ones who do speak,
though he makes room for
animals, also occasionally
speaking in a human voice and
being understood by human
beings,
making sounds that are--and
he's not talking about parrots.
He's talking about miraculous
biblical scenes.
He starts by saying the angels
do not speak.
They don't use the language we
do.
They communicate--Lucifer for
instance, he communicates,
but he communicates with the
other angels or with God
intuitively.
There is a kind of--so there is
a reality that escapes the human
language,
the language that we use,
there are some things happening
that we do not have.
Then the language is--it's only
human and yet,
it's not human because it's
actually a gift.
We couldn't really make it on
our own;
it's really God's gift.
This is the metaphysical
premise.
Who was the first--who are the
first people to speak?
He goes on: Adam and Eve in the
Garden of Eden.
That's biblical enough;
I think it's fairly clear.
What was the first language
that they spoke?
Hebrew.
Hebrew is acknowledged as the
primal language and he will even
go on so far as to say that
Hebrew is never really
extinguished by,
for instance,
either the fall of man,
of mankind, or by the building
of the Tower of Babel and the
whole question of Nimrod.
There's a whole story about who
this Nimrod is--
the famous biblical giant who
built the Tower of Babel,
an act which he even--he,
Dante, but this is very much in
the tradition of the so-called
patristic writings--
we'll see as the counter to the
descent of the word,
or the redemptive event of the
word made flesh,
is really the counter to this
human effort;
this ascent in pride of Nimrod
to try to bridge the gap between
earth and heaven.
And the effort to that fails.
He will go on acknowledging
Hebrew, but I must say,
not only he says that it
survives the story of Nimrod,
he says it has never really
disappeared.
He takes, and I'm only
qualifying it,
what we would call an
ahistorical viewpoint.
It was almost as if Hebrew is
accepted from--
it does not belong to the flow
of history and the reality of
the mutations to which all
things--
all sublunary things--are prone
and are vulnerable:
Hebrew is excepted from it.
I stress this fact because I'm
going to come back to this,
maybe toward the end of the
term, when we're going to read
Paradiso XXVI,
where Dante meets Adam,
and there blatantly,
he changes his mind.
It is as if something has
intervened in between the
writing of the De vulgari
eloquentia and the encounter
with Adam,
when Adam says,
look, the Hebrew language I
spoke completely,
vanished as soon as I ate of
the fruit--
of the forbidden fruit of the
tree.
Dante goes on and says there's
no trace of the original
language.
That is to say,
in Paradise, Dante's
ready to historicize the
question of human language,
but not in this treatise of the
De vulgari eloquentia.
He goes on describing the
descent of the word,
so it's a theology of language
and then Book I ends and he
moves on to Book II.
In Book II, Dante gives a
completely different--takes a
different direction in this
treatise.
He starts talking,
not about the grammar of
language,
what we can call the grammar of
that is to say the ordering,
how this language was ordered--
that's what I mean by grammar.
Of course it's a word that
explains letters,
correct uses of things,
but also the ordering of a
certain reality.
He talks now about rhetoric and
he becomes almost a theorist of
poetry and style.
He goes on explaining,
for instance,
he goes on wondering:
what are the three styles of
writing poetry?
And that you know,
because I have been mentioning
some of them.
You may recall the high style,
the medium style,
the middle style,
and the low style;
the style of comedy,
the style of tragedy and the
style of the elegy,
the middle style,
the elegiac style.
He even suggests that style
should never really be thought
of as a pure ornamentation.
Some of us maybe we do whatever
we think about that:
so and so has style.
We all remember the phrase that
the style is the man,
the character;
but sometimes we say,
well that guy writes with
style, meaning that he has brio.
He has a particular gift in
pulling together words and
writing sentences.
Dante sort of implies that
style is really a mode of
knowledge.
In the measure in which he says
there's a high style for high
reality and the middle style for
the middle reality--
the mixed world,
the elegiac world and then a
low style for the comical world.
He really says that if you
really want to understand those
who are far below:
the fisherman,
for instance,
or the clowns,
you cannot really give them
the--
treat them with the decorum
with which you treat the kings.
Kings speak differently,
the sublime kind of language.
Do you see what I'm saying?
There is an idea that style
becomes an instrument of
knowledge.
He goes on describing the
theory of the song,
which is the greatest poetic
lyrical form and it's the song
because it's a way of bringing
out the music of the language.
The music--Dante's
response--this is a little
historical detail,
it's responding to a poetic
revolution that had taken place
within--
in Sicily at the court of
Frederick II.
Because prior to that time,
the Provençal poets
would be writing,
composing poetry,
and would accompany their songs
with the lute,
the famous Provençal
poets' instrument.
The Sicilians had divided those
two modes.
It was possible to write poetry
in and of itself,
without the accompaniment of
music,
in the persuasion that the art
of poetry was the effort to
bring out the inherent harmony
of the language.
He discusses the song;
he discusses themes:
what are the great themes of
poetry and we alluded to that
with Bertran de Born,
because Dante says Bertran de
Born was the greatest in writing
war poetry.
The other themes of course are
rectitude--
the rectitude of the will,
that is to say,
a sense of the ethical:
what are the ethical directions
that one should take?
The word direction and
rectitude, they really have the
same etymology.
Then also love poems.
So this is the way he precedes.
He defines poetry, by the way.
He ends with a great definition
of poetry: that poetry is that
art that combines music--the art
of music--and rhetoric together
and he ends there.
It's unfinished.
Dante will go on writing other
things,
for instance,
a philosophical text about
ethics,
which he also will leave
unfinished and then will go on
writing the political text De
Monarchia,
etc., which he finishes.
This is the preamble to what we
are going to talk about today.
I think that the best way to
begin is to tell you,
since I'll be talking mainly
about tragedy and language,
I really want to tell you how
much Dante retrieves of the
De vulgari eloquentia.
For instance,
and I'm not going to be--
really giving you a lot of
details,
but some, so that you can be
persuaded about this--
that there's really a
deliberate pattern.
This is a deliberate
retrospective view that he takes
of his past, of a failure of his
own, of a certain way of--why
does one fail?
What is so unaccomplishable
about a particular task that--
I'm using the words that Nimrod
uses for his own Tower of
Babel--
I realize that it was an
unaccomplishable task.
And I find myself using those
words for Dante's earlier effort
in writing on the vulgar tongue.
Some connections between the
treatise and these lower--the
cantos of lower Hell.
Where are we by the way?
We haven't talked about that,
we got to talk about these are
the cantos of the lower Hell:
we are in the general area of
fraud.
You remember that, right?
We saw violence.
Now we see fraud,
but if you recall Canto XI
where the map of--
the ethical map of
Inferno had been given,
Dante distinguishes between the
sins of fraud and the sins of
treachery.
Treachery is a subdivision of
fraud because fraud can be
rhetoricians,
falsifiers in general,
flatterers, etc.
These are the--but treachery is
worse than that.
That's where we are now.
We're in the realm of treachery.
Treachery--the treacherous
sinners are those who engage in
a deceptive violation of the
trust others place in us.
This is not necessarily true
for all fraudulent people.
There's those who can
perpetrate a fraud on you
without even knowing you or
without even having anything to
do with you.
The question of treachery is
different.
It implies a violation of what
Dante calls the erasure of the
bonds of love,
because it implies friends,
family, country,
hosts.
I think, for instance,
Macbeth would belong to this
type of--the tragedy of
Macbeth--would belong to this
type of ethical judgment.
The erasure of the bonds of
love and nature:
it is as if the treacherous
sinners are really those who,
in betraying,
they really betray nature
itself.
It is as if something is being
said about that,
they annihilate all possible
ties within a community,
within the self and others.
Treachery is the language of
nothing.
It's a way of saying that
nothing matters,
there's no bond that I
can--that I could feel an
attachment too.
It's a--literally a severing of
self in the domain of a pure
arbitrariness.
I mean this:
I am above everything or I'm
below everything;
it doesn't matter,
but I certainly have no
attachments to anything around
me.
That's where we are,
there is so much to say where
we are in the context,
but the connections with the
De vulgari eloquentia.
I think that even the story of
Ulysses can be read in the light
of the De vulgari
eloquentia because it's the
story of a tragic style.
Dante had been describing the
tragic style,
and the tragic style and the
failure of the tragic style.
Even the canto--the successive
canto of Guido de Montefeltro
can be--it's literally the
counterpoint,
the rhetorical counterpoint to
Ulysses.
It's a story of the comical
style.
Certainly Bertran de Born is a
figure who,
for the first time,
and now the second time,
appears in the De vulgari
eloquentia,
and Dante has a great
admiration for Bertran de Born's
poetic art.
He says the Italians don't have
the language of the poetry of
war, but the one who has a
poetry of war and modernity is
Bertran de Born.
Clearly Dante has changed his
opinion here.
He may admire Bertran de Born,
but the strife,
the divisiveness that his
poetry fosters,
now sort of has made a victim
of him.
By the way, Pound writes a
great poem about--
Ezra Pound--about Bertran de
Born, but really keeping in mind
more that Bertran de Born of the
De vulgari eloquentia
than the Bertran de Born,
as far as I can tell,
of Inferno.
We come to Canto XXIX,
which I already looked at
that--
saw a little bit,
but I will come to Canto XXX,
for instance,
and Dante enters deliberately
now,
and on the face of it very
little--There is very little
here that has to do with the
De vulgari eloquentia,
but here though,
he's talking about two
experiences that define the
tragic mode.
One is, look at this:
"In the time,"
beginning from Canto XXX,
"In the time when Juno was
enraged because Semele,
the mistress of Jupiter against
the Theban blood as she showed
once and again,
Athamas so insane."
He's really talking about the
tragic text,
the Thebaid,
where the gods themselves
within the world--
the classical world--the gods
themselves seem to have been
wounded by exactly the same mad
passions that drive human beings
to destruction.
This is Juno.
Juno doesn't really die but she
will--she suffers the same
passions.
There's a language here of the
tragic and let's call it the
mythopoeic.
It's a kind of classical
theology being tied to it.
And then the story of the
Trojans once again:
"But no fury of Thebes or
Troy was ever so cruel against
any," etc.
Then even further on Canto XXX,
line 40, the story of Myrrha,
the young woman who--it's a
classical story.
It's an Ovidian story:
the woman who is inflamed by
passion,
incestuous passion,
and impersonates somebody else
in order to be able to sleep
with her father.
There is--this is part of all
this tragic, let me call it,
tragic perimeter,
but everything focuses on the
story of Sinon,
I think.
I like this idea of Sinon who
is an impersonator and a
falsifier.
You don't really have to know a
lot of Italian to know that
Dante is really punning on the
name Si / non,
which means yes and no.
The very representation of the
falsification of personality but
it's the--
so the tragic is tied to some
sense of identity,
people who do not know
exactly--and that's
impersonation.
Human beings who may not know
who they are and who may take on
some kind of either figuration
or the reality of somebody else.
So it's this idea of an
ambiguity already betrayed by
the name, so the connection
between madness and tragedy.
Let me move on to Canto XXXI
where Dante enters and now meets
the giants, clearly a figuration
and an echo of the De vulgari
eloquentia.
One of them is Nimrod.
So this is really a deliberate
reflection.
Let me just read a little bit
of this on line 60 and
following, where Dante hears
some kinds of sounds.
And every commentator of yours,
mine certainly does,
will tell you that Dante's
using just some gibberish.
Nobody knows what it means.
These are the words:
"Raphèl may
amèch zabi almi' began
the savage mouth to cry,
for which no sweeter psalms
were fit;
and my Leader towards him:
'Stupid soul keep to thy horn
and vent thyself with that when
rage or other passion takes
thee.
Search at thy neck,
bewildered soul,
and thus shalt find the strap
that holds it tied.
See how it lies across thy
great chest.'
Then he said to me:
'He is his own accuser.
This is Nimrod,
through whose wicked device the
world is not of one sole speech.
Let us leave him there and not
talk in vain,
for every language is to him as
his to others,
which is known to none.
We made our way,
therefore, farther on,
turning left,
and found the next a bowshot
off, far savager and
larger,"
etc.
And he meets other--a number of
other giants.
Why does Dante first of all
mention giants?
Both the De vulgari
eloquentia and here,
what is really the point of the
De vulgari eloquentia?
There is a way in which the
De vulgari eloquentia is
written from the viewpoint of
Nimrod,
because what Dante wants to do
is something exactly like what
Nimrod attempted.
Nimrod wanted to combine all
the possible languages,
that's how Babel,
the confusion of tongues comes
about.
He wanted to combine--to build
a tower whereby human beings can
reach Heaven.
And I said that it's really the
other side of the incarnational
word: the word that joins Heaven
and Earth.
One is one of descent,
the other one is the pride of
ascent.
Nimrod wants--this is the
giantess, this is--his is a sin
of--not a sin.
It's a trait,
it's a trait of his--of knowing
things.
He wants to occupy a kind of
superior perspective,
that's what his being a giant
means.
A superior perspective from
which he can really see the
whole of the world around him
and then be able to transcend
the world of contingency:
this is the problem with
Nimrod.
This is what the Tower of Babel
is about and the theological
answer is that you don't do this
by pride.
You really ought to do it by
humility, not by trying to go up
but really by going down.
What I'm really also saying and
we could talk about this,
that there is a connection
between pride and perspective.
The De vulgari
eloquentia is also a text of
perspectivism.
Do you know what I mean by
perspectivism?
What we have read so far.
Perspectivism simply means the
presence of viewpoints,
various viewpoints,
which one somehow manages to
control, or know,
all viewpoints.
In Dante, this is the case--the
way the whole of Inferno
is written.
The perspective on styles:
Dante uses all possible styles
that I have been exemplifying
for you here as we discuss the
poem.
He wrote--he uses the courtly
language and the courtly
rhetoric of Francesca,
the other court--the legal
court of Pier della Vigna,
the court of the--let's say,
the schools,
with Brunetto Latini,
the language of the prophets.
He uses all perspectives.
It's the whole of the Divine
Comedy is such a
perspective, a perspectivist
story.
Some of you might say,
well you really are using a
language that doesn't belong to
Dante's own culture.
That would be a very legitimate
objection because when we talk
about perspective,
we usually think about--this is
really the revolutionary
language of fifteenth-century
art.
You may--some of you may be art
historians.
You may know that,
though I could respond to you
that actually there was a
certain knowledge of perspective
earlier than Dante.
Nonetheless,
even if they did not have a
theory of perspective,
which I'll explain in a moment,
they had the practice of
perspective.
In art--we usually speak of
perspective in art,
and we usually link it with,
for instance,
a figure such as Alberti.
You know who he is,
this fifteenth-century theorist
of art,
who wrote a treatise called
On Painting,
in 1436, where he literally
theorizes that which other
painters from Giotto,
Dante's friend.
Dante's--they were together in
Padua for years when Dante was
in exile and Giotto was painting
in the Scrovegni Chapel right
there.
So you could imagine they would
be meeting;
they knew each other.
They were contemporaries:
one is a year younger than the
other.
Dante's a year older than
Giotto, actually.
So there was a practice of
perspective.
What is perspective?
For Alberti,
it simply means the discovery
that the mode of representation
practiced in the Middle Ages
really lacked depth.
Not only that,
lacked depth,
and that somehow the belief
that the world of appearance and
the world of reality coincided.
Perspective means that the
world that I see shifts,
changes according to the
position that I,
the spectator,
occupy in the field of vision.
I'm here and I can assure you
that I see things that you
sitting there cannot see and
vice versa.
You see things that I cannot
see, so the perception of
reality changes according to the
position we occupy.
That's perspective.
Not only that,
it also implies the possibility
of manipulation of the space
that we witness--we see--as a
particular space.
We can change it according to
distance, according to the laws
of the eyes, the position of the
eye, according to the hour of
the day.
I see things which are always
different.
So this is perspective and
therefore the language of
Renaissance,
the so-called
Quattrocento,
the fifteenth-century changes
the whole medieval idea of
representation where things were
represented the way they
appeared.
They say that's not true.
We are never going to give the
sense of the reality of things,
but the appearance of things.
So that's really the great--the
difference.
Dante uses this perspectivism,
which I repeat,
really means a way of
assembling various points of
view.
In the persuasion that this is
what really he has:
he's in exile in 1302;
he has been traveling all over
Italy;
and he thinks that he can go on
forging the language,
the vernacular language of
Italy.
He will go on--let me just go
back to say other things about
the De vulgari eloquentia
I didn't say.
He will go on writing about the
proximity of the romance
languages.
He invents this idea of romance
language.
And he says that the way in
which French,
Provençal,
Spanish,
Italian are connected
together--he says it's one
particle: the way we use the
'S' When he talks about
the Provençal,
he says they actually call
it--they say 'Oc' when
they are to make affirmative
statement.
He goes on talking about this
'S,' the language of the
'Sì,' the way the
language of what they know.
This is the way the families of
languages are being built
together.
Nimrod, to go back to the text,
the story of Nimrod and the
story of Dante seem to be
strangely very close.
There's more.
Look at what he does because
it's so--the link with the De
vulgari eloquentia is just
extraordinary.
Even this line,
that everybody thinks doesn't
mean anything:
"Raphèl may
amèch zabi almi."
If you look at it carefully--I
really want to tell you
something,
it is an imperfect--there's one
letter anagram of a Hebrew line
from the Psalms,
and the reference to 'sweeter
Psalms' next will tell you that
Dante's really giving you the
source.
The line in the Psalm,
Psalm 22, is Eli,
Eli, lama
sabachthani?
The fact that there is no exact
correspondence only means that
the editors have missed the
point: that they should amend
the text.
So it would be an argument for
textual emendation.
That's something that the
philologists are very careful
about doing but they always
welcome possibilities.
This is really--it's an
amazing--so he's using Hebrew
because that's what he had said
in the De vulgari
eloquentia,
that Hebrew--this is an
inverted, twisted language by
the builder of the Tower of
Babel,
we are not supposed to
understand it and yet behind all
confusion there is still
something intelligible,
that's the argument.
Behind all twisted appearances
of things there is a residue of
intellect,
of intelligent,
intelligible--an intelligible
message that is going to be
given.
What are these words,
by the way?
Eli, Eli,
lama,
sabachthani?--I am going
right past it very quickly in
the belief that you could--
that everybody will know it.
These are the words,
Psalm 22, they are the words
that Jesus on the Cross cites,
"Father,
Father why have you forsaken
me?"
It's really the tragic moment
or the moment of the Crucifixion
where the Son feels that he is
completely abandoned and that
somehow the whole divine play,
the whole divine order is no
longer responsive to him.
It's really the moment of the
theological despair,
they call it.
Okay.
Dante's aware that if
Nimrod--that's what he's--
Dante, I think is telling
Nimrod obliquely,
had he not been so stupid he
would have known by using this
kind of language,
the way in which it would have
been reaching Heaven.
The way to Heaven is the way to
go down into humility and not up
through the building of the
Tower of Babel,
and the confusion of tongues.
Then there is this whole
argument here which I'm not
going to go into,
but the confusion,
the perceptual confusion,
perspective.
Dante makes his--he is far away
and he mistakes the giants for
towers,
reference to this famous town
that is still--
if you go on the highway you
can still see Monteriggioni,
that's what Dante went by and
he thinks that the giants are
towers,
because you have no perspective.
Because in perspective,
you learn that you see
according to the distance of
the--where you arrive from the
object.
This is the basic mathematics,
the geometry that rules and
sustains the theory of
perspective.
Then it will continue with--let
me just go on to a further case
of this question of perspective
and I want to read with some
care XXXIII.
Let me turn to Canto XXXII with
more, pursuing this line of
references to the De vulgari
eloquentia.
Look at this,
"Had I the harsh..."
It's at the beginning of the
text.
Would you like to read?
We're reading from Canto XXXII,
line 1 to 12.
Student:  The version I
have is only Italian.
Prof: I'm impressed.
I didn't mean that--you go
ahead.
From Canto XXXII,
line 1 to 12 in English.
Student:  "Had I
the harsh and grating rhymes
that would be fitting for the
dismal hole on which all the
other rocks bear down,
I would press out more
completely the sap of my
conception;
but since I have not,
it is not without fear I bring
myself to speak,
for to describe the bottom of
all the universe is no
enterprise to undertake in sport
or for a tongue that cries,
mamma and babbo.
But may those ladies aid my
verse who aided Amphion to wall
in Thebes, so that the telling
may not be diverse from the
past.
O beyond all others misbegotten
crowd who are in the place it is
hard to speak of,
better had you here been sheep
or goats!"
Prof: Thank you.
Here, this is the beginning
that in many ways rehashes what
last time I called the
ineffability topos.
You remember at the beginning
of Canto XXVIII,
Dante there is talking about
the sublime, sort of parodic,
a sort of inverted form of the
sublime.
So the horror of what he was
witnessing was such that he
could not know that he could
find the metaphors for it.
This is now the deployment of a
variant of that conceit.
The conceit here is that
Dante's looking for a style,
he has perspective.
There must be a unique style
for this particular reality and
he starts, I cannot go on using
the language of familiarity.
I have to use the babbo
and mamma,
the language of the child
because this is just--
they are the treacherous souls
who have betrayed,
first of all,
family so there is a sort of
tragic resonance even around
that little motif.
This cannot be done in the
ordinary familiar language of
everyday because these sinners
have indeed betrayed all of
that.
Nor can it probably be done at
all,
because I'm aware,
and how he could not be,
in this area of treachery and
fraud,
that words and deeds do not
necessarily belong to him.
And I'm only paraphrasing the
text.
A search for style,
which he understands as a form
of what is convenient,
what is decorous,
what is appropriate.
That's the metaphor he uses.
It's, by the way,
an argument of the De
vulgari eloquentia,
the principle of convention and
convenientia:
in Latin the convenience of a
particular language over another
when one is dealing with a
particular reality.
The further problem of what
kind of style do I have?
Is it--can I get in order to
represent this kind of world?
He appeals to Amphion and the
building of Thebes.
Once again, this is a tragic
story of Thebes,
and obliquely,
he's also appealing to
something that he himself has
written.
Since Amphion is the poet who
moves stones by the power of his
language,
a version of Orpheus,
who placates,
tames the savage beasts within
the heart within us,
he wants to be a kind of
Amphion.
The fact is that he has written
stony rhymes,
he has written--he is moving.
It is a sort of retrospective
view that he takes.
He thinks that the only kind of
style adequate to this reality
is the style of the crazy poems
representing a crazy time of his
life for this Lady of stone who
would change him into stone.
We--an illusion to this
appeared in the canto of the
Medusa in Canto IX of
Inferno,
so that's really--it begins
with this search for a
particular style and Dante will
go on through this kind of--
this whole world of furthering
to the frozen iciness of Hell.
There is no fire, burning fire.
And now that's how the canto
ends.
And we start with the next
canto: "We already left
him," line 122,
"when I saw two frozen in
one hole,
so that the one head was a hood
to the other,
and, as bread is devoured for
hunger" So you know we're
approaching the most,
to me, the most unbearable
scene of Inferno,
the cannibalization:
a human being cannibalizing,
literally eating, the other.
I know that some of you may
have your sense of--your taste
can be different.
To me, this is really the worst
possible representation,
tragic representation here.
"The one above set his
teeth in the other at the place
where the brain joins the nape;
Tydeus gnawed the temples of
Menalippus for rage just as he
was doing with the skull and the
other parts.
'O thou who by so bestial a
token shows the hatred against
him thou eatest,
tell me the cause,' I said,
'on this agreement,
that if thou has reason in thy
complaint against him I,
knowing who you are and what
his sin,
shall yet requite thee in the
world above,
if this tongue I talk with be
not withered.'"
We are approaching a moment
where literally silence envelops
all possible representations.
It's something that
nothing--not all can be
altogether sayable.
It is something that
can--escapes the sayable and
it's that boundary,
we are at that boundary that
Dante places us.
This is--you know where this--I
have to read this exchange.
I will read it and then try to
comment on it.
I wish you could have a
discussion about this canto.
"That sinner,"
actually the Italian really
begins--
the sentence structure of the
English wouldn't allow it--
begins with 'the mouth.'
That occupies the primary place
in the line.
In Italian it's la
bocca,
the mouth.
The object is primary here.
In English: "That sinner
lifted his mouth from the savage
meal,
wiping it on the hair of the
head he had wasted behind,
then began: 'Thou wilt have me
renew desperate grief which even
to think of already wrings my
heart before I speak of it.
But if my words are to be seed
that may bear the fruit of
infamy to the traitor I gnaw,
thou shalt see me speak and
weep together.'"
If we had time and I were to
ask you whether these lines
remind you of anything in
particular,
I'm sure some of you would
immediately jump and tell me.
These are clearly an echo of
Inferno V,
Francesca's language.
The language of love has become
now a language of hatred,
because from the point of view
of Ugolino,
and that's part of his tragedy,
he can't tell them apart.
He does not know what love is
and what hatred is,
and he can exchange one for the
other.
You could even argue that
retrospectively,
the language of love of
Francesca maybe was also the
language of hatred,
but you would be pushing it
beyond the limits of
believability.
I think that Dante's really
echoing Francesca and the love,
and the romance with Paolo,
in order to explain this hatred
and that's the blindness of
Ugolino and I use the word
deliberately.
What he lacks is any
perspective on himself and on
the world around him.
He then continues,
"Thou art--
I know not who thou art,
nor by what means thou hast
come down here,
but indeed thou seemest to me
Florentine when I hear
thee."
The focus is on language.
Language here,
which is a part of one managing
to, first of all,
know the other and understand
the other.
They may know the inflections
of the dialects,
the Florentine dialect,
and they may even think that
indeed,
and Dante has a lot to say in
the De vulgari
eloquentia,
about the question of the
dialects and the instances that
they can communicate.
In effect, there's no possible
communication between the two of
them.
If I were to define for you the
rhetorical genre that Dante
deploys here,
it is that of what we call a
dramatic monologue.
Ugolino goes on speaking and
therefore he expects nor does he
get, any response from his
interlocutor,
his apparent interlocutor.
It's a dramatic monologue when
he goes on telling us the story
of his life the way he sees it.
You all know nineteenth-century
dramatic monologues in English
literature.
This is an occurrence of that
genre: I can speak;
I can tell you.
I can go on fictionalizing
myself and I believe that my
perspective or the way I
fictionalize myself will become
your reality.
Dante entices of course Ugolino
to do exactly that because this
is exactly--
this is the way in which you
are in Hell: where you go on
really believing that whatever
you tell,
that you can go on telling
stories and deceive yourself
that others are going to believe
what you are saying.
The reality that you're going
on constructing is everybody's
accepted reality.
This is one of the issues,
clearly, that we are going to
confront.
"Thou art to know that I
was Count Ugolino and this is
the Archbishop Ruggieri."
What an extraordinary line.
What makes this extraordinary
is, first of all,
the occurrence of what we call
attributes, titles,
and then the shift in verbal
tense.
Ugolino will go on attributing
time, "I was Count
Ugolino and this is...
" That is to say the
object of his hatred is
unalterable,
is timeless,
and that object of his hatred
is exactly what goes on defining
him.
I-- time belongs to me.
I know that I belong;
I have a history.
There is a history behind me
and there is--and this one here,
the reified the object of my
hatred is unchanging,
Archbishop Ruggieri.
There is the secular and the
sacred, if you wish:
Guelfs and Ghibellines,
with the idea that Ugolino had
really betrayed the side.
A Guelf became a Ghibelline and
a Ghibelline became a Guelf and
so on.
So it's the recapitulation of
all the Inferno satanic
sins we have seen so far.
"How by means of his evil
devices..."
"I shall tell thee now why
I am such a neighbor to
him…"
What another extraordinary
line,
because it's the idea of what a
neighbor is and what the
neighborhood has become.
This is the way:
the neighbors cannibalizing,
one cannibalizing the other.
"How by means of his evil
devices, confiding him,
I was taken and then killed,
there is no need to tell;
but what thou canst not have
learnt, that is,
how cruel was my death,
thou shalt hear and shalt know
if he has done me wrong."
Now he tells the story that he
was put as a prisoner in a
tower, which we are meant to
understand all the languages of
the other towers.
A tower which isolates him is a
tower in Pisa.
By the way it's really the
tower--this has nothing to do
with,
but I find it irresistible--If
you read the Cantos of
Ezra Pound,
some of the most extraordinary
poetry of his,
I think, comes from when he was
declared a traitor in the
aftermath of the Second World
War.
He was put in a cage not too
far from this tower of Pisa
which is really one of the most
beautiful part is where the
Scuola Normale in
Pisa,
and he writes this poetry about
the tower that he sees.
Clearly his own sense of trying
to understand what treachery
really means,
and what I'm really saying is
these are issues that keep being
present in the consciousness of
the leading imaginative figures
of our time.
He goes into this--the tower of
the hunger, as it is called,
and was shut up.
"...
had already shown me through
its slits several moons when I
had the bad dream which rent for
me the veil of the future."
He had dreams that--he has a
dream and the mistake he makes
is to think that the dream is
going to be real.
And the dream is this:
"This man appeared to me
as master and lord hunting the
wolf and the whelps,"
the word Guelf comes from wolf,
Guelf and Ghibellines,
"on the mountains for
which the Pisans cannot see
Lucca.
With hounds lean,
trained and eager he sent them
the Gualandi..
.that when I awoke"--he
has this idea of destruction,
the mutual destructions of the
wolf, etc.
"When I awoke before
morning I heard my children,
who were with me crying in
their sleep and asking for
bread.
Thou art cruel indeed if thou
grieve not now,
thinking what my heart
forboded, and if thou weep not,
at what does thou ever weep?
They were now awake and the
hour approached when our food
used to be brought to us,
and each was afraid because of
his dream and I heard below the
door of the horrible tower
nailed up;
at which I looked in the faces
of my sons without a word.
I did not weep,
I so turned to stone within.
They wept, and my little Anselm
said…"
By the way,
to understand how there is a
counter: there is a sort of
movement between the horror of
this tragedy and the tenderness,
the pathos of it.
One of the ways in which Dante
suggests this,
is the use of diminutives for
Anselmuccio,
this little kid that he has,
this kid.
"Thou lookest so,
father, what ails thee?'
At that I shed no tears,
nor answered all that day,
nor that night after,
till another sun came forth on
the world.
As soon as a little ray made
its way into the doleful prison
and I discerned in four faces my
own look, I bit both hands for
grief;
and they, thinking I did it
from a desire to eat,
rose up suddenly and said,
'Father it would be far less
pain for us if thou eat of us.
Thou didst clothe us with this
wretched flesh and do thou strip
us of it.'
I calmed myself then,
not to make them more unhappy,
that day and the next we stayed
all silent.
Ah hard earth,
why didst thou not open?
When we had come to the fourth
day Gaddo threw himself
outstretched at my feet saying,
'My father why dost thou not
help me?'
I don't think it's far fetched
if I were to ask you to overhear
behind this question of one of
the children,
exactly an echo of the prayer
of Jesus on the Cross that we
heard,
that we read, a few cantos back.
There is a way in which the
violence inflicted on Ugolino's
children seems to repeat or
re-enact the great drama of the
Christian sacrifice.
"There he died,"
also crucified,
in fact, "there he died
and,
as thou seest me,
I saw the three drop one by one
during the fifth day and the
sixth;
therefore I gave myself,
now blind."
That's what it is,
the lack of perspective:
he sees nothing.
He therefore has no distance
from anything,
nor can he tell things apart or
distinguish things one from the
other, "...
to groping over each and for
two days called on them after
they were dead.
Then fasting had more power
than grief."
An extraordinarily ambiguous
line because we really do not
know what he's saying.
According to Rodin,
for instance,
who will go on making a statue
of this, it's at the--at the
MOMA, you can go and see that.
The story is that of--that
Ugolino ate his own children,
"then fasting had more
power than grief."
I yielded to the appetites,
the urging of hunger more than
grief.
Or maybe he's saying just
something else.
Maybe he's saying then fasting
had more power than grief,
I really died of fasting for
hunger rather than for the
grief.
We don't know,
and I think that part of the
tragic mode that Dante is trying
to convey to us,
is that we are left--and this
is by the way,
is Borges' reading.
Borges writes nine lectures on
Dante, what else?
Realizing the importance of
number nine for Dante,
he writes nine lectures on
Dante and one of them is on the
story of Ugolino.
And he says,
he actually wants us to leave--
he wants to leave us in
suspension,
to believe that it's possible
that he may have been eating the
children,
but maybe it is the sensibility
of so many critics have been
offended by this suggestion that
he actually could go on
cannibalizing his own children.
I think that Borges is right,
that we are not supposed to be
able to tell apart,
that the ambiguity of that line
is never going to be quite
resolved.
It's going to be forever there.
But, the most important element
of this tragic occurrence and
Dante--before I go on let me
just say, "Ah,
Pisa..."
Dante goes on into an
apostrophe against Pisa,
again with this language of now
he talks, he breaks the silence.
"Ah Pisa,
shame of the peoples of the
fair land where sounds the
sì..."
Another little touch,
another little echo of the
De vulgari eloquentia.
That is to say,
in the moment where he's
dealing with treachery,
which I call the most
nihilistic of all sins,
because you really declare null
and void any bond that you may
have with others,
he uses, and the irony is,
to me, glaring the affirmative
part.
As if here, there is a possible
affirmation, there is none.
"...
where sounds the
sì,
since thy neighbors are slow to
punish thee make Capraia and
Gorgona shift and put a bar on
Arno's mouth so that it drown
every soul in thee."
This is really the kind of
language that Ugolino himself
had used when before the
consumation of the tragedy,
he really begs the earth for an
earthquake,
that the earth may open up and
swallow all of them.
Here Dante is using exactly the
same language.
The idea that it is so
horrifying, he's a spectacle;
that he has been in the tragic
spectacle he has been
witnessing, that the whole world
here could be an apocalyptic
ending to the world.
To go back to the key
issue--there may not be time for
a discussion today and I
apologize--
but the real tragic event
though, what is the tragic event
other than...
"What if Count Ugolino had
the name of betraying thy
strongholds,
thou shouldst not have put his
children to such torment,"
So this has been the
crucifixion of innocence.
"Their youthful years,
thou new Thebes,"
Pisa is the new Thebes,
a new Thebaid that we have been
witnessing now,
"...
made them innocent,
Uguccione and Brigata and the
other two named already in my
song."
This is really the
tragic--Dante has been using now
the tragic language indeed,
that he had been hoping and
theorizing in the De vulgari
eloquentia and then they
move on.
What is the really tragic
occurrence?
The tragic occurrence is in the
very presence of the
Christological language in this
canto,
because the sacrifice of the
cross means one thing and one
thing only: that now that all
violence is finished and because
we have found the scapegoat,
the voluntary scapegoat,
who goes around saying that
we're all innocent and that he
is the guilty one,
that's how we are
declared--that's how we are
redeemed,
that's why we are made innocent
once again, right?
The story here,
re-enacting and echoing the
story of the cross,
seems to say the
futility--seems to announce the
futility of that sacrifice.
Retrospectively,
he says that that sacrifice too
was just one of the senseless
acts of violence that have
happened in history and that
punctuate human history.
Of course, this is not the end
of the poem,
but it's the most desperate
part of the poem,
because Dante comes to believe
that the law of history,
that the law of the world is
really a tragic law.
And there is something absolute
about it, and not quite
escapable.
We shall see how he's going to
move through this and I really
have to go into Canto XXXIV a
little bit.
I will not say too much this
time.
Canto XXXIV is where Dante
meets Satan.
So the encounter with Satan is,
first of all,
that which gives incredible
coherence to the whole movement
of Inferno,
because as you remember the
story of Inferno began
with the neutral angels,
those who had been sitting,
watching the spectacle of the
disruption of the cosmos.
Now the neutral angels at the
time of the Lucifer's rebellion
of--
against God and now it ends
with Lucifer,
so it's really as a kind of
angelic,
cosmic proportion.
The other thing that I have to
say is that if you imagine,
those of you who are readers of
Milton and Paradise
Lost,
and you know what a brilliant
rhetorician Satan-- Lucifer--is
in Paradise Lost,
you'll be disappointed.
In fact, T.S. Eliot,
who writes a commentary of
this,
he says, I really recommend the
first time readers of the
Divine Comedy to skip Canto
XXXIV because it's strange that
Lucifer-- Satan doesn't speak.
And that was exactly the point
that, I'm sorry to say,
T.S. Eliot,
at this time,
really had probably had never
read the De vulgari
eloquentia.
He's not supposed to speak,
because he's one of the angels
who really do not use the human
language,
but more importantly,
because he represents evil
defeated.
From this point of view,
Canto XXXIV stands in radical
sharp contrast to Canto XXXIII.
In Canto XXXIII we saw--we have
witnessed the sovereignty of
evil.
It is as if it were all
engulfing and hovering over all
of reality.
Here now we witness exactly the
opposite, how Satan becomes a
reified, dumb object and
actually an instrument for the
pilgrim's ascent.
It's going through the body of
Lucifer that the pilgrim can go
on,
and the guide and Virgil can
turn themselves upside down and
finally re-emerge to the light.
The rest of the canto--good.
I think that we are going to
have a few minutes,
but I have to say something
about the rest of the canto.
The rest of the canto deals
with a cosmological argument and
the cosmological argument is
where does Purgatory come from?
And Dante gives an
extraordinary--invents--a poetic
myth.
And the poetic myth that he
invents is that when Lucifer
fell at the time of the grand
angelic disruption,
the first rebellion against the
Deity,
the earth retreats out of fear
at the approaching of this
fallen angel and re-emerges on
the other side of the
hemisphere, the southern
hemisphere.
That's the beginning of
Purgatory.
You see the connection from an
evil act,
the chances of redemption,
how in affecting Dante's
cosmos,
there is nothing which cannot
be utilized,
no evil which cannot be
utilized to the ends of the
good.
Everything--the real defeat of
evil is when that itself can
become the stepping stone over
the threshold of evil itself in
order to reach the purgatorial
island.
The last little detail that I
will tell you is--I ask you to
read the last line of Canto XXX.
You'll like this.
It's a little detail that
you'll like, I hope.
The last line of Inferno
is: e quindi
uscimmo a
riveder le
stele--
and therefore we came out to
see once again the stars.
Just a little detail to remind
you about the extraordinary love
of symmetry in Dante's poem,
that each canticle will end
with that same word
stele,
stars, stars, and stars.
That is to say each canticle
ends with us looking up,
reminding us of where we are
and still longing for the stars.
I have come to--in a hurry I
have reached the end of the--of
Inferno.
There's Purgatory now
and then see if there are
questions.
Yes?
Student:  Can you say a
little bit more about how Dante
was trying to construct almost
like a total perspective through
his construction of the various
languages,
from seeing different forms of
Italian and trying to get an all
encompassing perspective,
can you say how that relates
too?
Prof: Yeah,
the question is,
can I say more--good question.
The question is can I say more
about how Dante's trying to
construct how he uses total
perspectives and--
you mean both in the De
vulgari eloquentia and here?
Yes, thank you,
because in effect,
I was hoping that someone would
ask me this question because I
really did not tell you how
this--
the De vulgari
eloquentia is completed here
and why couldn't Dante complete
the De vulgari eloquentia
when he wrote the tract.
When he wrote the tract,
he wanted to unify--
he believed that they are--the
dialects,
fourteen dialects in Italian,
he acknowledged,
he recognizes fourteen dialects.
He knew some of them very well
and he wanted to make a unified
language out of that,
a kind of artificial language,
a sort of--
let's call it Italian
Esperanto: something that you
could bring together.
And what he was lacking,
so much so,
that there are those scholars
who work on--
who have been working--I don't
agree with that,
is that almost Dante seemed to
have a kind of--
seemed to be in agreement with
the so-called logicians,
those who have a kind of--the
idea that language has a sort
of,
let's say, a Cartesian
linguistics.
There's a kind of rational
structure to it and that can be
really remade.
The point is that when he
writes the De vulgari
eloquentia,
this is true.
I don't buy the idea that he's
following the logicians of the
Middle Ages, the grammarians,
who are really logicians.
What he really lacked was a
historical sense and the little
detail that Hebrew was still the
surviving language from the
creation of man to our own time
because--
and he had a good theological
argument for that,
because it would be
inconceivable that the Redeemer
of the world would use a
language other than the language
that had been employed by Adam.
When he comes to
Paradise,
to the Divine Comedy he
completely changes view.
In Paradiso XXVI,
as I'm going to tell you,
Dante says no,
no.
Hebrew disappeared
with--immediately after Adam
fell.
With the fall of Adam through
the Garden,
there was no longer the primal
language and he goes on
elaborating the idea that God
does not use any language of--
that is to say,
human beings are the letters
and syllables of God's language.
It's not Hebrew,
it's not Latin,
it's not Greek,
it's not whatever,
it's not Chinese,
that's really the--We are the
syllables: that's Dante's idea
of Paradiso XXVI.
This was the--that's the real
change.
What does it mean in terms of
the Inferno?
It's that he had understood
that, in order to write about a
unified language,
he had to descend.
He could not go on the tower
and from there watch all the
qualities: aesthetic,
what is the sweet--what is the
well combed language and what is
the less well combed,
the harsh language,
what are the sounds that he
really should be applying and
adopt into Italian.
What he really understands that
in order to have a unified
language you have to descend in
the political realities of these
cities?
That's the difference between
the De vulgari eloquentia
and the lower Inferno,
a sense of history,
that's really the difference.
To see this--the sense of
history--you can be in a tower
as Ugolino is,
and be blind,
or you can be in a tower like
Nimrod is and do not even know
what you are talking about,
who can go on completely
reversing,
messing up, and confusing the
Hebrew that he should have
known.
Do you understand what I'm
saying?
That's really the difference
between the two.
Good question because it
allowed me to focus on a detail
that I probably didn't explain
very clearly.
Student:  I don't
understand how he could have
said that Hebrew died at the
Fall.
Prof: You don't
understand why?
Student:  I don't
understand how Dante could
think--
Prof: Make that
statement?
Student:  Yeah,
is that what you're saying he
said?
Prof: Yeah,
that's--I don't think that
there are any traces of Adam's
language.
The question is why--it's a
sort of predicament and I don't
know if it--
he says he doesn't quite
understand why--
how Dante could say that Hebrew
died with the fall of man.
That's what he--Adam will tell
him.
He meets Adam;
he's another poet,
because he's the one who names
the world.
Student:  Where do the
Scriptures come from in Dante's
>
Prof: The Scriptures are
not in Hebrew,
Scriptures are--the language of
Jesus, for instance,
is Aramaic.
We have to be careful about
what kind of--
the kind of--is that Adam's
language or is that the
language--
it's a language that changes in
time,
that's all, that's all he's
really saying.
But the New Testaments are in
Aramaic, for instance,
which is a dialect.
Yes?
Student:  So this goes
back a little bit to the last
lecture,
but looking back over the
entirety of Inferno,
it seems like Dante expresses
different levels,
I guess, of sympathy or pity
for the people who are trapped
in certain circles of Hell,
especially for the sowers of
discord,
and then later in other cases,
like at the end of Canto
XXXIII.
He's happy to be with Charles,
to someone who's being
tormented--
Prof: Yes,
Bocca degli Abati.
Student:  What's that?
Prof: Okay go on.
Student:  Right,
and I just--
it's interesting though the
re--the different relationships
that Dante has to--
the different reactions he has
to these punishments.
Given that he's essentially
created all of--
the Inferno is supposed
to be a representation of divine
justice,
but it seems like overall Dante
is the judge and executioner
here.
Given that the whole--how
sincerely does Dante believe in
this divide?
Does he think he's--
Prof: In this--
Student:  In the divide
between himself as this narrator
who can feel pity for the
different--
for the people trapped in
different areas of Hell versus
Dante as sort of the--
I mean, in some sense,
he's the creator of all of
this.
Prof: Absolutely.
Student:  He has
assigned everyone to each level
of Hell--I know this is a broad
thing but
>
Prof: It is.
Student:
>
I kind of wanted to see some
comment on that divide.
How sincerely is this a vision
to him?
Prof: The question is,
since Dante's--Dante,
the pilgrim,
has different responses to the
figures whom he has created,
sometimes he's tender and
sympathetic,
sometimes he just kicks them,
if that's the scene that you
are referring to,
and they're all his creations,
how sincere is he in his
vision?
The response is that I would
formulate it a little bit
differently, but that's fine.
We agree that Dante has--is not
the indifferent spectator to all
of them and I think that what
matters to him most is to show a
degree of passionate involvement
with whoever they may be.
He's not going to be
sentimentalizing about all of
them for a number of reasons.
He's very sentimental with his
teacher.
I think he's really very
sarcastic with Pier della Vigna
whom,
you remember,
he mocks at language of his,
the contrived--I thought he
thought, I thought...
That's not Dante's language,
that's really Pier della
Vigna's own poetry that Dante's
picking up.
I think that he is very--he has
a sense of pathos,
and maybe he's also seduced by
Francesca.
Francesca, you can't put this
past her, that she's trying to
seduce him as well as she
seduces, or lets Paolo,
seduce her.
When he comes further down,
the relationship is no longer a
relationship of this tenderness,
of forms--now there's this
anger.
Anger at what?
At the extraordinary horror of
what human beings can do,
and there's nothing--Dante
calls fraud, the sin peculiar to
man, to human beings;
the sin peculiar to human
beings because they are--they
have a reason that becomes part
of their premeditations,
part of their machinations of
evil.
And I find that repulsion he
has, I find that
very--dramatically speaking,
very convincing.
It's still part of a judgment
that he is making and it's not
an attenuation at all of that
judgment.
The anger with which he attacks
Pisa,
that the idea that he speaks
prophetically there,
why isn't this whole place,
disappearing,
this is--I think that--to me
is--you could say it's sincere.
I wouldn't be using that
language but I think that's it
dramatically very powerful.
And I don't know if you would
agree that that's probably the
best way of referring to this
term--to describe this
situation.
Would you agree?
Student:  Yeah.
Prof: I find it
dramatically very apt.
It's--because it's a
consequence of the genuine
horror--can you imagine?
I mean you had the
earlier--even the diviners with
a shape--a human shape twisted.
The head turned around.
Then the alchemists,
also represented in a kind of
twisted form.
It's this twisting of the human
image and this--and the reality
of what human beings can do and
ongoing and this hatred has
taken over.
I think that he's approaching
them too.
There is a way in which I was
saying he echoes Ugolino when
Ugolino says,
'oh earth, why didn't--wasn't
there an earthquake and which
would swallow everything.'
I mean, the language of the
eater, the cannibal,
so to speak.
And then Dante just says:
why isn't there some kind of
great drowning of all this?
Why aren't the islands just
moving and be a barrier,
so that the whole town will go
under?
I think that there is a way in
which he's almost doing the same
thing.
That's it, almost,
re-enacting the kind of sense
of nothingness that Ugolino had
shown to him.
Obviously, he does not agree
with Ugolino.
It's not that there is a kind
of complete identification with
him.
And how do we know that this is
not going to be the case?
He's writing, Ugolino isn't.
The poem is what rescues Dante
from yielding to the temptation
of absolute despair and
therefore distinguishes him--
distinguishes his own temporary
impulse for nihilism,
with the nihilism that
distinguishes,
characterizes all the sinners
and above all,
the treacherous souls.
Maybe we should stop here;
we're going to talk about
something so much more serene,
Purgatory,
next time.